hey 42 here every galaxy has a
supermassive black hole at the center of
it the galaxy NGC six two four zero
within the Ophiuchus constellation is a
super galaxy that was formed as a result
of two smaller galaxies colliding with
one another as a result NGC 6240 zero
has not one but two supermassive black
holes at its centre astronomers believe
that one day these two black holes may
very well collide with one another so
what would happen if two black holes
collided the collision of two black
holes is such a rare event that it has
never actually been observed by
scientists here on earth we have however
ran extremely complex computer
simulations to determine what the result
would be if two black holes did collide
firstly it's important to understand the
enormity and sheer density of black
holes
a typical supermassive black hole can
have a mass of anywhere for many
millions to several billions times the
mass of our Sun the largest black hole
we have ever found is in the galaxy
Homburg 15a the black hole at its core
is 15,000 light-years across and has an
estimated mass of a hundred and seventy
billion times that of our Sun or more
properly referred to as a hundred and
seventy billion solar masses so what
would happen well there's basically two
possible outcomes of such a catastrophic
event which possibility depends on the
speed in which the two black holes are
traveling how fast they are spinning and
the angle of their collision if the two
black holes are spinning at very high
speeds and come together at just a right
angle the smaller black hole will be
slingshotted away from the bigger black
hole and sent hurtling through space
similar to how two spinning tops bounce
off each other when collided but the
second more likely outcome is that they
will slowly come closer and closer
together until they can't escape each
other's grab
and they eventually become one this
process would be unbelievably violent
when this happens the resulting black
hole is known as a binary black hole as
the two black holes start to merge they
would appear to be a distorted mass of
matter but as they come closer and
closer together the resulting black hole
goes for a process known as rink down
this is when any distortion in the shape
is slowly dissipated and the new binary
black hole becomes more and more
circular until any asymmetry is lost and
the black hole once again becomes a
nearly perfectly circular disk of
swirling death the energy emitted from
the collision will be so great that it
would send ripples through the
space-time fabric of the universe just
think about that for a second two black
holes colliding would cause the very
fabric of the universe space and time to
ripple like a gigantic pebble in a pond
these ripples are known as gravitational
waves gravitational waves have never
been observed here on earth in recent
years we have built large instruments on
earth that are capable of detecting
gravitational waves far away in space
and even more powerful instruments are
currently under construction why is it
so important that we detect these
gravitational waves
well gravitational waves are a
fundamental component of Einstein's
theory of general relativity detecting
they're man's not proving their
existence would be irrefutable evidence
to back up Einstein's theory as well as
increasing our own understanding of
gravity and how it behaves so to
summarize if you see two black holes
about to collide get the hell out of
there thanks for the view subscribe for
more 42
[Music]
you